did see a few games that they show
during the presentation one was like a
new 3d Mario game that they didn't
really they just kind of showed it and
didn't address it also like one quick
thing they showed Skyrim but then it
came out after that Skyrim's not confirm
for the console Oh even worse well
that's Bethesda being we didn't announce
this right why would if like the hit
like we have every intention of putting
it on this it's part of that that cycle
they put it into like we have the time
when we will announce these things we
have not officially announced this game
yet even though you've seen it running
on this console don't and there there's
also the possibility that Nintendo could
have jump the gun where they could have
talked with Bethesda and said like this
is something we'd like to put on the
system this is what it'll look like it
may didn't get permission yet put it on
the real force their hand I love to
mention todd howard at home drinking a
glass of wine or something see scattered
spit-take alright TV that's my game and
then nobody what's the matter the
bastard stole my game no uh yeah then
like the 3d Mario what is what was that
have I'm sure like Nintendo has had some
sort of statement about it like what
else not announcing nothing like Avenue
and said like no I mean its potential
what we see of that is a very small
slice so I've even seen conjecture that
is just like an endless like a 3d runner
and it was possible because you're
literally just running on a single track
I don't think it will be I think will be
a full 3d Mario game yeah but i think
that was also more proof of concept and
like an idea yeah yeah it's hard to say
it's a surprise that there's gonna be a
mario game on this nintendo console but
i guess it was the the heat and the
excitement of the moment like that we
saw it really what was that cuz I Justin
like played Mario far more than I have
any say I don't recognize that level
from anything you know I thought maybe
were just like 3d land or whatever 3d
world we have the most recent one was 3d
World 3d world um but I guess I wanted
to talk about like what other kind of
ways they could like make cool games for
this council I mean like however
far-fetched you want to get my ways
though we know what they're going to do
and then in the beginning there's gonna
be a mario game there's gonna be we know
zelda like that's the only actually
confirmed title for splatoon spittoon is
they should that is that a port yeah but
there was like well i mean probably a
port there were new hairstyles someone
got all excited no way
I intendo switch your hair I think they
should mario kart as well on there yeah
like but are these games that are just
gonna get updates on the wii u are these
full new title so it felt like what we
saw that these were slight modifications
on existing game so mario kart 8 red
button I feel like someone pointed out
in mario kart on the in the preview
video that you able to have to widen
once yeah yeah it's this that
graphically it looked very simple shell
blue shell first and second place you
also I both of you blue show yourself
that'd be sick I do myself hahahaha what
were you saying in a way those aren't
even the things that are interesting
those are the what we expect we know
this is gonna come to every in the Tendo
console there's gonna be a Pokemon game
it's like what level are they going to
take that too but the thing that I think
is interesting to talk about would be
third-party titles and even do does that
matter it's been so long since a
nintendo console has had a strong third
party support and i have a ps4 at home
most of us have an xbox one or ps4 or a
pc that plays all of the the biggest
games that we want to play like skyrim
do we need a nintendo console to also
fill that gap no i mean we need the
nintendo console again nintendo games
and then whatever it does otherwise
that's kind of like the icing on the
cake and i know that sounds really like
fanboy ish like it's worth it just for a
nintendo stuff but like I mean by and
large that's kind of true if you like
what they do like investing a couple
hundred bucks to play their games isn't
that big of a leap so yeah like I don't
think they're gonna be able to sell it
to anyone but Nintendo fans like by the
same problem they've always had apart
from the wii if this is as powerful as
an xbox one I PSO the computer
conjecture we don't know what it's it'll
probably be close to a ps3 you use xbox
360 not we use pretty close to ps3 I
mean they're not terribly far off but I
mean this will be more powerful in the
Wii U but I think it would come pretty
close to ps4 xbox one I think they
almost have to know I don't think that's
possible battery life battery life would
not allow that because that's a thing
that would make it I say a replacement
but at least something that you might
turn to if you're if you're looking at
what's the next big game I'm going to
get if you're not someone who's invested
in the playstation 4 pro or the xbox
Scorpio sure but like so for me it's the
second screen experience thing right if
you look at okay yeah i can play remote
play on my Vita it's a shitty service it
doesn't work that way
oh I could play remote play on my laptop
for my ps4 but that's like a big
cumbersome laptop right to actually have
this really easily convertible thing you
just pick it up you plop the you can
leave the controller's attached if you
want to but it really does make just
playing any game so much easier when
you're not relying on your TV and so if
they can deliver like decent performance
for games that sure maybe they're out
already or their new games that aren't
as high tech that's still offering
something totally different than just
purely playing a console game on a TV
like the Wii you couldn't handle what
these games are doing cuz the gamepad
was just a receiver this game pad will
have the tech in there so you'll you'll
be getting really good experiences on a
small screen that's really convenient to
play when you're done with it you just
plop it on and charge it play on TV like
it just sounded like such a great
scenario to me that i'm not i don't
think the power is going to be the thing
i think it's the convenience of
transforming how you play games and i am
right assuming that if you are to take
it like on the go as like a more 3ds
kind of type thing it's gonna be the
same going to be robbed people right but
it's also the same game you're playing
TV there's no scenario where i don't
know like in an ideal world you could be
playing a 3d Mario on your TV like with
the home console then you go take it as
a 3ds and it becomes too d no no I think
of anything you'd see the resolution dip
or the framerate dip but at the same
time they could also dialed back some
special effects maintain the frame rate
but again the smaller screen you don't
need as much high resolution so right
and I don't think that we're going to
see a huge power boost like there's been
some conjecture that when you put it
into the console at least from what
they've shown in the video when you put
it into that base stand that there could
be a graphical improvement of a of like
having extra processing power in the
base and the way they showed it I don't
think that's possible because you're
basically hot swapping graphics cards
they did it in an interview they said
that no it will not provide more
processing power in the base but if you
go back to the battery life thing they
could dial back some of the processing
like literally you know kind of like
hold back the processor when it's not
docked and then just let the processor
work as it should when it has more power
and battery life isn't a concern so
technically yet the doc could provide an
envelope for better performance but I
I'm pretty sure they were on record
saying that no there's not like an extra
thing in the base station so what's the
switch going to do from a gameplay
perspective that the wii u didnt be
because the wii u was basically a
standalone club that was
my second console and I played it purely
for Nintendo games and ultimately it
felt like it didn't deliver like what's
gonna be different about the switch I
don't know what obviously don't know
what will be what i really hope is that
nintendo deliver into something that
most people aren't talking about they
really nail a good operating system for
this thing because people are going to
treat this device like a tablet you
couldn't do that with the gamepad it was
cumbersome it was big it was low
resolution it didn't have great tech so
this will essentially be a Nintendo
tablet right if they can sorry I'm lots
of specifics of your question what can
they do did I mean what what is it that
will make this different than the wii
like it's very rare games or titles it
would make it yeah no I don't think it's
going to be the software that makes a
difference apart from more third-party
games that is probably going to be the
only difference we see here I really
think this is more of a tech move and
sort of a twist on concepts that they've
dabbled in before and even just taking
mobile gaming and just showing all these
companies what they're doing wrong like
why has an apple or you know any Android
manufacturer come out with like a really
good software platform that works a
really good hardware that lets you just
focus on games without all the other
like BS that comes with working with iOS
and the Android like Nintendo will
really be able to be like this is the
mobile high-tech gaming platform and
it's also your console that was the main
appeal to me like watching the trailer
and seeing what they're trying to do
with it is like the 3ds has always
worked well for me for local connection
over Wi-Fi or whatnot that was the most
feeling thing to me I'm not going to
stop playing basketball to play NBA 2k16
like they did in the trailer but it was
cool like to see like four people around
playing it like the console games for
all intensive purposes may be like
downgraded graphics like you said but
you know within close proximity r as
opposed to like having to play over like
you know like almost a LAN party was
just these smaller screens yeah and
that's the most appealing thing to me
for and I'm just like thank you through
my head like what kind of games like
it's all the first party stuff it's
mario kart it's you know like the mario
co op mario games what not i don't
better be metroid that's better be
vegetable one I guess like everybody
wants because the new Zelda we all
played at e3 I think that was like
gamespot's you know like unanimous kind
of game of the year and there's awesome
and it seems like it's a return to form
in a lot of ways i'm curious how they're
going to use the switch to kind of do
something new zelda because I feel like
Zelda has always been every zelda game
that comes out like the first one in
each count
was kind of a proof of concept for the
console Skyward Sword finally nailed
motion graphics was a twilight princess
showed that they could sort of be used
on the the we I'm wondering what they
might be doing with Zelda to show the
switch off there are some weird patents
that Nintendo has handled recently like
one that has like a light projector on
the side of the tablet that literally
shows people interacting with things
like with light hitting their hand and
then like so I think the patent shows
someone like throwing a ball towards the
screen and then like their friend being
able to actually play it if that comes
true and that's a part of this there's a
lot of weird-ass possibilities but i
think really nintendo is going to focus
on just I hope making these just good
standard games that aren't relying on a
gimmick right that aren't forcing you to
use the gamepad because I look what I
can do right like that was such a huge
problem for games like Star Fox like
that was the pinnacle of Nintendo's
hubris and they they couldn't even admit
it at the time and I feel like this is a
very firm like statement like okay we
heard you guys like here's just a
straightforward thing that just gives
uses tech that actually makes it more
convenient for you not to show how
clever we are sure as a company yeah
stop trying to prove yourself and just
get out of your own way when you said
Metroid I assume you mean like a 2d or
do you like I mean I love the primetime
no I just want a good metroid game I
just want to be back in that World
Federation for shouldn't do it for you
hold games that I don't want our multi
ball split-screen multiplayer and they
showed that look with that ridiculous
NBA basketball demo where you say oh I'm
gonna go play basketball now we're all
gonna share half a controller and play
split screen like that that seems
horrible like well I'm not gonna split
my phone screen and do multiplayer on
I'll play bomberman that way Oh have you
got NBA but I play some games like that
yeah I can't I can't kick bombs at my
friend I can play basketball five feet
away with that not very well but I could
play basketball I love video games but
the real thing is right next to you just
go do that or go home and play NBA 2k16
I'm just being a curmudgeon right now
but yeah that is the antenna switch so
those are kind of like our impressions
on the tech and the actual what software
might come out of it let us know what
you think in the comments below